how's um raspberries peterpan soul
there's a hack a fan-made hack for alien
isolation that came out yesterday and it
allows you to play with the oculus rift
which is pretty terrifying all right
it's weird I heard about it but I guess
they didn't go through with it for some
reason
but yeah I'm excited to check it out you
brothers know how I am with a with
horror games on the oculus it usually
doesn't end well for my pants it ends
well for you bros but not for my pain
I'm gonna I'm just gonna put it on it
totally works
hahahaha oh god what is happening a
flare oh yeah I have my meat out it
feels so weird stepping into a game that
I already played with that so my legs
what are you doing again yeah kick your
[ __ ] that's me alright what else we get
flares I have my flamethrower this is so
weird
I aim with my face - that's really weird
that means I'll just show I'll have to
show the aliens my beautiful face for
them to be terrified on me it's probably
gonna be the opposite but here we go
alright hello
what's in the house Oh God Gary Gary Oh
God
ah this is a terrible mistake bros we
should not have done this Carrie are you
okay Gary where are they I hit him I hit
him I don't see anyone on the radar Gary
what happened here Gary why you look so
down man why you look so why you gotta
be so Gary don't you know I [ __ ] flame
throw you out darkness don't come out
wherever you are
don't come out Lana then I said yo what
are you doing
you look pretty though alright let's
close this door okay
ever wake up Oh got it
yeah what is ah ah well that could have
been a little better
oh [ __ ] me I assume my objective is to
not get brutally murdered but who knows
these days I want to use my Flair hi
poets shut up flare is that lipstick for
me oh did you come that's [ __ ]
disgusting
check death it's so nice and cozy in
here hello all right no one's on the map
we're fine aah aah aah no
does shun aah their son their son what
what now now my legs
sorry I guess see he doesn't care if I'm
sorry or not you're better than this
pros you're better than that
alright attempt three will set us three
just like that TV shows about witches
did you watch that no one watch that
[ __ ] come on let's be honest a [ __ ]
90s two TV shows man alright I like
really focus this time this kinda wanted
to [ __ ] with him
not literally Oh God Oh for [ __ ] sake
don't [ __ ] me oh let's get drunk and
weird
I can't lean anymore well I guess I have
my oculus advantage [ __ ] [ __ ] I
would good Gary hang tight I'm going to
get oh god I'm dead I'm going to get
help
cuz I love you Gary and I ship us
together on this spaceship do you know
what kind of weird double shift that has
to be taken do you know what kind of
measurements
I've been oh god he just came out you
just came out don't make oh god
Gracie oh God
what the [ __ ] no fight to be in real
life that's right didn't think so
Brett woo that one's for Gary but sick
stop with the damn Vince Jesus trying to
give me a headache
Sally Sally who ate your face Sally oh
they were hey hey wait uh okay oh god oh
god it's truly all right all right I'll
get let's do some little hacking um all
right I better hurry up then I suppose
that went that one and that one uh-oh
well close the damn door woman yes I
find myself out I didn't think that
through okay all right doing it do and
get breast my nurses oh oh I wish I
could have played through the game like
this this is amazing this wicked and I
don't use that word ever that is [ __ ]
awesome all right let's keep going we
got this press I know you're with me I
wish you could each my nose for me that
would be great Oh God
don't [ __ ] with me
I have a flamethrower I should be my
slogan for my YouTube town don't [ __ ]
with the flamethrower right I don't even
know how that's possible what a guy what
is in here what hello what goes around
comes around Justin said that not the
bad one
all right I'm gonna loot what is good
I don't see Oh God nevermind oh god oh
god I gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta
gotta gotta get dad boom-boom he doesn't
see me right he doesn't see me right
oh god dad [ __ ] ass ah I wish I could
butter that pooper up alright yeah this
doesn't look creepy at all let's go here
this is not at all looked like a place
to go when you'd want to die okay Bruce
man I'm not scared of Oh got it why am i
why am I on the floor
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I think that's the one we
need
what do you doin woman he's coming oh
wait no maybe then we do it we activated
it just yes all right let's find the
other one no problem no problem
every inch of my body is itching uh what
okay okay
Oh God okay okay all right we're fine
we're fine rest I just hide in the
corner and hug the wall kiss the one why
not that according to Michael a
calculations and what seems that we're
pretty damn [ __ ] so we can't
night-night
nice got shot - knock knock
now what is rock now now what no are we
fine fine it's America huh all right
that's fine
a coupla come on come on huh
where you gonna be so rude don't you
know I'm human too
we're fine according to my calculations
we're [ __ ] fabulous collect all the
scraps hide underneath the table like a
real man okay can you just go away
nice gone long gone maybe not maybe he's
coming back
what the [ __ ] do you come from all right
get some Ebola ethanol I mean and toilet
paper I knew that [ __ ] there must be a
machine I hear it I hear it let's just
go for it yes oh my god Sally sue what
did they do to you I'll never forget
this Sally sue pump that [ __ ] up
pop that [ __ ] up vodka pitcher what
just happened oh [ __ ]
Nate Nate big day what any wallet in you
up oh okay then well that's very nice of
you
I [ __ ] flame your ass don't think I
don't see AK [ __ ] hack ah ah no we
tried so hard to loose it uh alright
that was a lot of fun I hope you guys
enjoyed this little thing I wanted to
check it out it's pretty cool I wish I
had multiplayer you know what I wish she
had multiplayer if one guy could play
alien while the other people were an
oculus I would just be so much fun oh
well maybe they'll update that it seems
like they have stuff going on but they
don't want to announce it until it's
finished but anyway I hope you guys
enjoy this episode if you did click that
like button I'd really appreciate it
means a lot to me that you do that and
that's all for me for now hit subscribe
homebrew today and stay awesome round
and it comes to breakfast